[Music]
so like i said earlier we're going to do
some weird today we're going to talk
about some crypto
why steve is not here steve don't know
anything about crypto suck it steve i
know it shits out about crypto so just
ask me go say it all in one sentence
block three point block 3.0 web channel
block 3.0 3.0 sync
web channel
it's on the wheel all of your stuff
chain dude
everything's on the web chain you know
what i'm talking about block three point
no send a web chain up there wise words
from romans it's a color here we go
so
everybody wants that he's neither skinny
thank you bart 3.0 i do i do know that
not everybody here watched the super
bowl i didn't but for those of you that
did
did you guys see the crypto commercials
with uh
larry
david elder with larry
is this about coinbase
the coinbase
oh yeah i saw that that was actually i
actually signed up for that you know
they spent they spent [ __ ] like 14
mil on that commercial
uh reported seven million that was a
crazy commercial though are we gonna
watch the commercial it's just the
[ __ ] qr code it's like you get all
these commercials like movie trailers
all the [ __ ] it was like jurassic park
right before and then just this site it
was like it was kind of like elevator
music right and it was just a bouncing
qr code on the tv for like 15 20 seconds
and that's and then i'm looking at it no
words no actors just a bouncing color qr
code but the ad spot cost seven million
dollars wow and then obviously you see
that you're like what the [ __ ] is this
you pull your phone out 60 seconds 60
seconds
it was just balancing
did it crash on you because i heard
that's what was going on is [ __ ]
hilarious like they spent all this money
on the commercial and then when people
went to go on the couldn't handle the
traffic yeah it crashed well yeah it did
crash but the thing is it crashed
because it worked so well that's good
well where does it where does it go
instantly to so the thing is it would go
straight to the coinbase app or the
website and if you signed up from that
qr code and you were first time sign on
they would give you 15 free bitcoin wow
i got entered to win a million dollars
of bitcoin nice yes we'll find out
aka it was a really [ __ ] effective ad
like amongst the most like effective
that i there are many crypto commercials
take that art you don't need those there
was there was an ftx commercial
there's a crypto.com commercial and you
know it's your regular super bowl spot
you got some three or four major crazy
celebrities that are somehow getting
into this script about crypto like they
even [ __ ] care about it or anything
like that and then there's like these
interesting concepts of the of the
storyline that are like oh that was
weird maybe i'll remember it but
guaranteed when this coinbase one went
off like everyone even at my super bowl
those shindig like everyone was
immediately pulling out the phone
they're like what is this
you know what i mean because you don't
know what it is but you know what a qr
code is next thing you know it's
everybody's like oh it's coinbase and
it's way more of a conversation than
just sitting there and watching it and
going oh a coinbase commercial very
interactive i heard they um
reached an all-time high and and and
coin like sign ups and wallets and stuff
too
just that day alone wow it was crazy and
it's crazy because we we've been talking
about this for the last
more than four years
and then people were like that's a scam
it's a fad it's going away and i'm like
damn dude
sucks to be you
i think it was so evil sounding i think
it was
[Laughter]
do you remember the first time that like
tesla cars came out yeah yeah and it
wasn't this like
correctly wrong it didn't feel like it
was this like major shift in like
worldwide anything no because everyone
thought it was just another fisker
exactly right
plus plus we had like the [ __ ] the
leaf or whatever did you buy or did you
have were you going to no oh well there
was a google car and all these other
things the point is when that when the
electric cars would come out it didn't
seem like a revolutionary like the world
is changing the worldwide adoption but
the moment that i personally felt like
oh [ __ ] the world is for all gonna start
changing is at the previous super bowl
where suddenly you saw like ford's
electric vehicle like there were like
four or five
electric commercial uh vehicle
commercials as well at the super bowl so
now you know that like the major
companies that are willing to spend
millions of dollars on like seconds of
ad space
suddenly if they're willing to project
this it's like that's the messaging of
where the future is going to go and
that's what i felt because there's an
equity they know about that you don't at
the time and now i feel like that we're
sitting in the super bowl now this year
and we're seeing massive crypto
commercials it kind of like is
finally spurring that kind of momentary
change or that needs massive adoption
and that's kind of are you saying your
crypto wall is gonna explode they're not
gonna be here anymore is that what
you're really trying to say if my crypto
law explodes are you gonna steve green
us absolutely it's been my
aren't you glad that like i don't know
like like butt plugs don't have the
budget to have a super bowl commercial
or else we'd all just be like what is
that i'd [ __ ] love that
i'm even better the qr code is a free
buffalo well i gotta put it in
it's free it's major adoption in their
house there's an equity we don't know
about
like because that would be like if i had
like an obscene amount of money i would
like [ __ ] send that image or that qr
code to [ __ ] a rickroll or something
oh yeah me too i would just troll the
world man or just sell butt bucks
imagine if that was the way to connect
to the metaverse like a [ __ ] like
you're going into the matrix but it's
through your ass and it's like you want
to tap in and then you [ __ ] have a
butt plug that gets you into the
metaverse
but like the best version of the metal
it was an hdmi port this whole time you
can just see your thoughts yeah oh [ __ ]
it's compatible yeah that one
that means you can't take a [ __ ] or be
in the metaverse at the same time hey
guys i gotta log out real quick i'll
take a [ __ ] you have to pull it out i
didn't think about that
and then what if you smell the the plug
it smells weird maybe maybe don't maybe
don't smell the plug
dude i got hella roasted by my high
school teacher when they were like oh
what would you do if you had like five
thousand dollars right now and i said
like oh i'm just uh put a billboard with
my face on and go sup san gabriel like
i just thought that'd be like funny
gabriel and then the teacher was like
she goes okay why do you think uh you've
never seen that before and i was like i
don't know because it's really creative
and she goes no it's because rich people
don't do stuff that's stupid
no now you need to do it damn that
teacher's hardcore awesome
you need to like put their name over
there like suck it miss so-and-so suck
it saying gabriel
let's get killed
you're just like five thousand dollars
doesn't make you rich teacher [ __ ]
i know that's how much you might make in
a year but
absolutely five thousand dollars would
probably get you like 30 seconds on a
billboard
oh five thousand will get you no you get
a billboard really for a whole month
yeah you get a month maybe off of a
obscure street or some [ __ ]
and i was already like all right this is
done
no uh crypto crap we should get a
billboard
i just get a careful boy you're really
good [ __ ] do it joe that's not what
rich people do joe well it's okay
because we're not rich exactly you
really could but it's billboards there's
a reason why i lose money
and i'll show you how
join my master i haven't really seen
i've still yet to see billboards
translate into real sales from any
experience i've had firsthand like
usually the figures are terrible there's
a lot of lawyer ones i'm gonna say i
wanna know about all the legal ones
cause i cuz i've thought about it too i
was like if i we're not james wang you
know that's [ __ ] james wang that
billboard sells itself is that dude
that's like eight eight eight eight
eight eight yeah accidentally yeah yeah
i was about to say that actually
[ __ ] adriano's insurance
adriana
is that the lady with the german
shepherd yeah
she gets me every time man well shen you
know every time you buy multiple
policies you're just like ah she just
goes insurance and then there's just a
dog you're like can i insure that dog
shen yoon works that's all i gotta say
send you inspiration is all of the above
but it's always a conversation of
wanting to go and never going but let's
all go with boys have you seen like a
trailer of shane yoon
yeah it's good it's lit it looks good
i'm down to go let's go i'm gonna see
that flag dance that's a big statement
if you go do they do like peeking opera
over there too they what or they do like
it's almost a semi-anti-communist
chinese sentiment down yeah let's go
heard it's a cult too right
it's like falun gong it's not cultish as
much as it is uh
i guess i guess if it's anything
semi-anti-religious or religious ties
into cultism that works
i think it's easier to call it there's a
lot of cool [ __ ] that colts make so i'm
down
have you seen the david koresh musical
even
musical
let's go see both of them
if i saw that show my netflix suggested
i'd be like i mean
i'm already on a watch list right we're
like in the last act of shenyun it just
becomes the damage
i would pay money for that it just me
like i want to see a musical waco
ancient china become waco texas
i wanted to go around i wanted to hdmi
butt plug i want to see the transition i
feel like the transition yeah what
propaganda are they showing because all
i heard is just it's a sick it's like
cirque but china version and then all
proceeds go to fighting companies
because they're they're they're um
depicting the history that china is
erased
oh so like where the monkey god is
coming in yeah and [ __ ] [ __ ] up
china's like that didn't [ __ ] happen
see all i'm saying is these billboards
obviously work because we're hella
talking about it shenyun is inescapable
that's like the biggest even adriana's
insurance just got [ __ ] jk we never
we're broke
that's the first billboard that's going
to be on the moon
100 percent
or accidents and if you go to if you go
to a restaurant and mars i guarantee you
on the placemat there's going to be
james wayne that guy's everywhere bro
that guy's in my dream dude
[Laughter]
i dream about that guy i know you're
gonna go to a chinese cafe
chinese [ __ ] cafe fall restaurant in
mars
fallout 99
you know what i mean there's gotta be a
flow restaurant online it's gonna be
james wayne somebody's gonna make so
much sense to have a pho restaurant on
mars it's so cold probably just you warm
yourself up
you're
logically where was your logic gonna go
this was logical oh man dude but you
can't take a [ __ ] in the metaverse
that's logical if you're plugged into
your ass honey just said that's logic
because we already just we already
discovered that ash is a usb port right
yeah then it's like usbc though by the
way you know oh we know it's an hdmi
port i'm sorry
big difference people need to start
wasting more money you can i'm sure you
can blanket statements
one of those people that if i had the
money i would definitely use it stupidly
and that's why we don't have money
[Music]
you